foreign
think of it as magic hey everyone my
name is Maya in this video we will learn
what machine learning is and how it is
more of a computation strategy than some
out of the box magic
do you guys know Osama Bin Laden
location was predicted by a set learning
supercomputer known as Nautilus
also Google's deep learning machine
learning program can detect breast
cancer with an accuracy of 89 percent
all this became possible due to the
knowledge and implementation of machine
learning now you must be curious to know
more about machine learning we are going
to learn machine learning but before we
begin if you haven't subscribed to our
Channel already make sure to hit this
subscribe button and don't forget to
press the Bell icon so you will never
miss any update from Simply learn so
without taking a minute more let's see
what we will cover in today's video
so first we will discuss what machine
learning is then we will move ahead to
understand the importance of machine
learning to learn any technology it is
important to know its advantages and
disadvantages
we will continue our session by
understanding the different types of
machine learning followed by some
important machine learning algorithms in
this video we will have a look at some
important machine learning tools further
we will have a quick look at the
applications of machine learning in our
day-to-day life and finally we will end
this video by knowing what the future of
machine learning holds so without any
further Ado let's begin
do you guys know from predicting the
weather condition by examining Cloud
designs in the Babylon time in the 18th
century BC to using electronic messages
phones analyzing satellite images in the
20th century the process of weather
forecasting has evolved essentially
throughout the long term however in this
digitalized period forecasting climate
and recreating long-term climate
patterns have been accomplished with the
assistance of machine learning models by
examining volumes of information by
computer
so the question arises is it possible
for a machine to learn from past
efficiences just like we humans do
and the answer to this question is yes
and this became possible just because of
machine learning machine learning is a
subpart of artificial intelligence which
is broadly defined as capability of a
machine to imitate intelligent human
behavior
like humans learn from their past and
acquire knowledge through experience
either directly or shared by others
machine acquired knowledge through
experience shared in the form of data
let's understand with the basic idea of
how machine Learning Works
firstly you have to input the pass data
or training data into the machine
learning model
after that machine learning model learns
from the data and creates logical models
in the end when you input new data to a
machine learning model it predict output
according to the logical models
after understanding what machine
learning is equation arises why we need
machine learning
even though machine learning is
constantly developing with countless new
technologies it is still used in
different organizations machine learning
is important because it aims with the
perspective on patterns in user Behavior
operation design and support the
improvements of new products also as the
volume of data over performs people move
in the direction of computerized systems
that store data and machine learning
models can predict proper solution this
will reduce human efforts time and
increase work efficiency
like Facebook Google Uber top
organization use make machine learning
as their master store
machine learning has demonstrated
history in almost all the sector like
marketing e-commerce Banking and many
others as of now we are well aware of
how machine learning is important let's
have a walkthrough of the advantages and
disadvantage of machine learning
before diving deep into any technology
it is very important to understand its
advantage and disadvantage here are some
advantages of machine learning first one
is low error rate if coded properly
machine learning models would have a
lower rate as compared to humans machine
learning models have incredible Clarity
accuracy and speed second was in
automation
machine learning reduces the need for
human resources at every step as it
automatically learns and predicts the
output third one is wide range
application almost every sector takes
advantage of machine learning to reduce
human effort and get quick results
talking about Healthcare machine
learning is used for screening or to
predict healthy risk in healthcare in
education machine learning is used to
give each student an individual
educational experience or in banking
enables more accurate reporting by
automating creditors for both Banks and
customers the fourth one is Trends and
patterns identification we can identify
the numerous amount of Trends and
patterns for example the stock market
uses machine learning prediction model
to predict Trends and patterns for
companies growth and other Financial
assets
and the last one is continuous
Improvement using machine learning you
can see continuous Improvement in your
results machine learning is capable of
learning from the information we provide
them
as every coin has two sides machine
learning has advantages as well as
disadvantage let's have a look at some
disadvantages now the first one is
costly machine learning models are
expensive and time consuming to build
rebuild and repair the robotic repair
can reduce the time and Manpower
required to fix machine learning models
but again that is too pricey second one
is limited time and quality resources
machine learning needs a lot of data but
it also needs good quality data to learn
efficiently the third one is storage
the backup and servers are continuous at
work and are responsible for recording
the acquired information this keeps on
building up the course for a machine to
learn the potential information is a
continuous activity thus there is a need
to store the information different
storages and cloud services are not
sufficient to store this amount of large
data and the last one is unemployment
machine replacing human jobs can lead to
several unemployment now that we have an
understanding of the advantages and
disadvantages let's move forward and
discuss different types of machine
learning
machine learning is classified into
first one is supervised learning second
one is unsupervised learning third one
is reinforcement learning fourth one is
semi-supervised learning let's
Understand Each one by one in detail
in supervised learning the machine is
trained with the help of label data with
external Guidance the machine learning
model is given a small preparation data
set to work with let's understand this
by example suppose we input data as an
image having known label data of dogs in
this way machine will learn and create
some logical models when we input a
known data the Machine model will
categorize them as per their
similarities and patterns that is we can
easily sort the unknown input as a dog
supervised machine learning can be
further classified into two types first
one is classification second is
regression and the next one is
unsupervised learning
in unsupervised learning machine Act
without any guidance in this technique
machine act upon the data that is
neither classified nor labeled without
any external guidance for example
suppose we input data as an image having
both mango and banana which the machine
has never seen in this way the machine
has no clue about the characteristic of
mango and banana so we can't categorize
them as mango and banana yet it can
categorize them as their similarities
pattern and contrast that is we can
easily sort the above picture into two
parts
unsupervised learning can be further
classified into two types which are
clustering Association now let's have a
look at reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning is hit and trial
method in the absence of any data the
machine is bound to learn from its
experience only
let's understand with an example suppose
we input the image of a square machine
learning model will respond using the
past experience suppose it gives output
as a circle
then feedback is provided as wrong it's
an image of a square now the machine
learning model will learn from this
feedback and it will predict the correct
output when we input the same image next
time
reinforcement learning can be further
classified into two types positive
reinforcement learning negative
reinforcement learning
and the last one is semi-supervised
learning semi-supervised learning is a
sort of machine learning algorithm that
lies between supervised and unsupervised
machine learning or it takes label and
unlabeled data to predict the outcomes
to beat the disadvantage of supervised
learning and unsupervised learning
algorithm the idea of semi-supervised
learning was presented
the principal point of semi-supervised
learning is to utilize accessible
information successfully after
discussing what machine learning is
importance of machine learning the
advantages and disadvantages of machine
learning and its types let's move
forward to see commonly used algorithm
and machine learning in computer
programming terms an algorithm is a set
of well-defined instruction to solve a
particular problem
it takes a bunch of information sources
and delivers the ideal result in this
modern time there are lots of machine
learning algorithm used today in this
video we will put highlight the most
widely used machine learning algorithm
the first one is support Vector machine
algorithm also known as svm sem
algorithm falls under the supervised
machine learning technique next is the K
nearest neighbor algorithm it falls
under the unsupervised machine learning
technique further we have hierarchical
clusting algorithm which uses an
unsupervised machine learning technique
the last one is decision tree algorithm
which is most widely used algorithm in
the machine learning area the decision
tree algorithm falls under the
supervised machine learning technique
after this let's move forward to see
some tools used to train the models in
machine learning the current market is
flooded with an array of machine
learning tools like tensorflow Apache
singer spark Amazon machine learning
Python and many more which help in
training the models and the system let's
have a look at each of them first we
will start with tensorflow tensorflow is
a free and open source programming
library for machine learning key
features of tensorflow are fast
debugging scalable and many more Google
uses tensorflow to power machine
learning implementation in products like
search Gmail and translate and the next
we have Apache singer a purchasinga is
an Apache top level project it is used
for developing an open source machine
learning library key features of Apache
singer are distributive learning memory
optimization time profiling and many
more
Technologies City group and many others
in the next one we have Apache Spa
Apache spark is an open source formed
together analytics engine Sparks come
with the features like pre-processing
data transformation and many more spark
machine learning tools power the Toyota
customer 360 inside platform and social
media Intelligence Center
and the next we have Amazon machine
learning tool the most promising
strength of AWS machine learning tool is
that they are based on a highly
comprehensive Cloud platform
Amazon machine learning comes with the
features like accurate prediction
reducing operation overhead improving
customer experience and many other many
pigments like Netflix and Facebook use
AWS as their machine learning service
and the last one we have pytor
pytorch is an open source machine
learning framework in view of torch
Library
the features like distributive training
a robust ecosystem Cloud support and
many more
companies commonly using pythons are IBM
Qualcomm Walmart and many more
let's move forward and cover
applications of machine learning
knowingly or unknowingly machine
learning is playing a major role in our
day-to-day life here I have some
application of machine learning which
will improve how machine learning is
helping everyone all over the globe
we all use YouTube Netflix and Facebook
in our day-to-day life the machine
learning algorithm figures out the
patterns of what type of video movie we
watch and thus provide a suggestion
accordingly Tesla is the one of the best
companies which manufacture self-driving
cars using Electric solar and integrated
Renewable Energy Solutions caused by
Tesla are already making their way to
the market and ready to show the world
of the power Ai and machine learning
another application of machine learning
is speech recognization
we all aware of voice assistance like CD
by Apple Cortana by Microsoft and Alexa
by Amazon these assistant translate is
speech to text and use machine learning
to provide result machine learning is
also used in medical sector to determine
various diseases with the help of
machine learning the patterns and the
symptoms of disease can easily be
diagnosed
and the last one is forecasting weather
forecasting and financial forecasting
are application of machine learning in
which future outcomes are predicted
using historical data it involves the
use of statical modeling data mining
technique and machine learning for
prediction so as we have seen all the
major aspects of machine learning we
will finally have a look at the future
of machine learning the commercial
impacts of machine learning can really
hold a huge potential to generate
significantly High productivity growth
machine learning is one of the quickest
developing field on this planet at the
present time machine learning Engineers
are in high demand the average salary of
machine learning engineers in India is 9
lakh per annum and the annual base pay
for U.S machine learning Engineers is
one like thirty thousand dollar all the
ventures as of now have countless usage
in machine learning which is the
fundamental inspiration behind why there
is an interest for occupation in that
field the growth in technology has that
in increasing demand for professionals
who can understand and make use of the
vast amount of data present companies
like Facebook Google Tesla and many more
are constantly hiring machine learning
engineers
the future of machine learning looks
bright and will pave the path to many
more inventions and with that we have
reached the end of this video
I hope you guys found this video
informative and helpful if you have any
doubts or feedback feel free to leave
them in the comment section below we
will be happy to help you if you like
this video please subscribe to our
Channel and don't forget to hit the Bell
icon thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here